and our number one we had Jake Tapper
here from CNN and as you know he's the
number one diehard Christmas movie
truther I believe it is not a Christmas
movie and was very pleased to see on
Twitter over the weekend that the Bruce
Willis roast that went down on Comedy
Central was recorded by Comedy Central
soon to be aired on Comedy Central
finished up with a joke from Bruce
Willis saying that die hard is not a
Christmas movie and we have now on the
phone line I believe the individual who
is this true wrote the joke for him
Sarah Tiana here on the Richardson show
how are you Sarah I'm great how are you
guys well we're thrilled to have you
let's put it that way so Sarah was this
provided to Bruce Willis by you to say
yes
it was reminded by me it was actually we
they were like four of us in the room
Network writing his script and I have to
say that like when I just like threw
that out there at the end like let's
just say like he's here for one reason
and one reason only and that's to say
that guy heart is not a Christmas movie
there was everybody just laughed and
there was no protest like it just went
in the script and it was like one of the
only depths of stay for like a week
nobody even fought us on it y'all just
were like yeah that's great
okay so now where do I go with this one
Sarah did did Bruce what was Bruce's
reaction when it this joke was presented
to him to say to finish it up he had no
reaction here is this like that's great
so does that mean he agrees that die
heart is not a Christmas movie would you
say would you read into that assessment
yes I mean I mean with that same
assessment you'd have to say he agrees
with all the jokes that he said but I
think yeah I think Bruce is okay
well Sara okay no I said he's agreeable
and obviously I would place my stand-up
comedy moment in a podium in Europe more
than capable hands
I would definitely do that but based on
you as a top-notch comedian top-notch
comedy writer would you not agree the
best roast jokes are formed with a germ
of truth at the very center of them oh
absolutely that's why they work just
because there are so many truthers out
there so the joke works because we we
know that it's a debate and even though
it's ridiculous debate it would be
really funny if frequent squash the
debate now why would why why is it
debate ridiculous Sara when clearly
there's only one side of this debate and
that is not a Christmas movie I agree
you know and I feel like you know I live
in a house with a man who disagrees with
that and that's only because he wants to
be a bro at Christmas and not watch
girly movies and that's why I'm here and
that's not really on me you can't change
the story of a movie just because it
fits your Audiology but you can't change
the facts of the movie which Jake's so
perfectly laid out in our one what kind
of movie or kind of actual office throws
the party on Christmas Eve for their
employees that makes no sense whatsoever
so it's not even based in reality and if
you change the holiday to just like a
kid's birthday those of you works
exactly the same you can't do that with
a real Christmas you can't take
Christmas out of the equation Tianna
but that's what happened and now you're
just attacking the integrity of mr. na
kotomi rest his soul okay you're not
gonna give Sara completely ever
questioning mr. naka tell me I'm
affecting everything in that movie you
know it's a really funny story which was
that on day one of shooting they made
him jump off a two-story
building on to like a giant air mattress
and the the director he was like why
would you have me do this on the first
day and the director was like oh because
if something happened to you I could
just replace you with another Sara
I appreciate you adding the sanity and
the clarity that you have provided thank
you thank you okay Sara T on everybody
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience